by adding the meta viewport tag to the
head element of the page we tell the
browser that we know what we're doing we
need to use the meta viewport value with
equals device width which instructs the
page to match the screens width in
device-independent pixels this allows
the page to reflow content to match the
screen sizes whether rendered on a small
mobile device or on a laptop adding the
attribute initial scale equals 1
instructs the browser's to establish a
one-to-one relationship between device
independent pixels and CSS pixels CSS
pixels are what we're used to working
with most of the time and really the
only one I need to worry about without
initial scale equals one some browsers
will keep the page width constant when
rotating to landscape mode
they also scale the content rather than
allowing it to reflow